-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy and Grammy
nominated TV
and record producer,
you know, from shows such as
"The X Factor,"
"American Idol,"
and "America's Got Talent."
His new show,
"America's Got Talent Extreme,"
airs Mondays at 8:00
right here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-[Bleep]
-Oh, God!
-♪ Tricky, tricky, tricky ♪
[ Audience screams ]
-Oh, no too far, man!
[ Music climbs ]
-♪ It's like that job
that we don't quit ♪
-With a drift.
That drift was for you, Travis.
-Please welcome to the show,
Simon Cowell. Hello, Simon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello, Seth.
-Simon, I'm just going to start
by saying this.
That might be the best clip
we've ever shown to introduce
a guest
in the history of this show.
-Thank you. I mean, that was
that was a wild show.
-Yeah.
This is a I do want to start
by asking how you're doing.
You have a broken arm
and I I believe
you broke this bike riding.
Is that correct?
-It's not as bad as your hand.
-Yeah, no, exactly.
I mean, that thing still shows
and I think
it's not coming off the makeup.
But you broke your back
bike riding in 2020, as well.
Now are you?
Are you bad at biking?
[ Laughter ]
-Well, yes, actually.
I mean, yeah,
for that to happen,
what was it within like a year?
Yeah, it wasn't great.
The irony was, is that part
of my kind of like physio
was to cycle,
so it didn't quite work out.
So this is going to be on
for about a month or so
and there are literally
will be back on my bike again.
-Well, that's I mean, this
speaks to
your commitment to cycling.
There's nothing,
it seems at this point,
there's nothing that
will keep you off your bike.
-No.
-Yeah.
-I do love it, I'm just not very
good at it, like you said.
-Now this show your fellow
judges -- you have a WWE star,
you have a motocross
professional, and yourself --
Is it weird that
you're the one in a cast?
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not the only one,
actually, Travis,
who's, you know, like you said,
one of the other judges,
a week before me was jumping off
a building or something.
The parachute didn't open
so he broke his pelvis.
Then a few days later,
I broke my arm.
So I sent him a note saying,
"We're both in is like, you
know, we've got broken bones.
You've just got
the better story."
-Yeah, yeah, definitely on set.
You want to make sure
you tell yours first.
You don't want to,
you don't want to follow
the parachute
didn't open story.
-But there is a kind of an irony
on this show
that two out of the three
judges, like you said,
are watching the show
with broken bones right now.
-Do you ever, do you -- when you
watch these extreme stunts
and meet these extreme
sport athletes,
do you ever feel the pull
to try what they like to do?
-A million percent.
There was one guy who --
Yeah, he was on episode one,
shot himself out of a cannon
and he went about
100 feet in the air
through this flaming ring.
And I was thinking
if I hadn't broken my back,
I think I would have
done that one.
-Well, then I can't believe
I'm saying this.
Breaking your back
might have been the best thing
that ever happened to you.
-Exactly.
there's always a silver lining.
-Now, you know, I'm wondering
as you sort of branch out,
certainly into "America's
Got Talent" as a world.
You know, I would imagine
for a long time people
thought you could
only judge singing.
And then now
you judge everything.
Do people on the streets
ever ask you to judge a talent?
-Yes, Seth.
-They do?
-I get it. Yeah.
And sometimes
very uncomfortable situations.
I mean.
The most famous, I think,
being -- this is a true story --
A couple came up to me
in a restaurant
and said we'll pay you
X amount of dollars
to watch them having sex
and will I judge it?
And I said, "Well, how much?"
And stupidly said no.
If you're watching.
I'll do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Simon, I got a look,
you can say no.
What was it?
Well, it's X amount of dollars.
What's the number
they throw out?
-I think from memory, I mean --
I think it was about 150 grand.
-Wow! That's a weird number.
-Yeah.
I mean, I don't know
how they calculated it.
-Yeah.
I wonder if they were like,
"Should we do $100,000?"
"That's not enough."
"$200,000?" "Don't be crazy."
[ Laughter ]
He's not all that.
-I mean, you can, but I would
have offered a discount.
But like I said, if you're
watching, I'm available.
-Yeah, they're like,
it's 150 grand.
It won't take long at all.
-[ Laughs ]
-You have, you obviously
discovered some huge stars
over the course of your career
doing what you've done.
Yet there have been a lot of
people who have won competitions
who have not had as long careers
outside the bodies of the show.
Do you feel like you have
a pretty good eye
when a season of one
of your shows is over of knowing
who actually has the talent
for a career beyond it?
-100 percent. Yeah.
I mean, we always use this
expression Seth, which is,
you know, forget about the show,
it's like a bubble.
Outside the show
is the real world.
And we try as much as we can,
as long as they're on the show,
to kind of prepare them
for the real world,
because that's where
the real competition begins.
So whether it's "Got Talent,"
you know,
try to get a residency in Vegas,
the singing shows,
I mean, all of the artists
you've got to compete against.
So I think it's great training.
But like with anything,
there's no guarantees.
But luckily, over the years,
you know, we were just lucky.
We met some amazing people
over the years.
Normally you can tell, sometimes
in the very first audition,
this person's going to have
a massive career.
You can just tell,
like Carrie Underwood,
I remember her first audition.
It was, we weren't having
a great day
and she came in and I'm like,
"Wow, there's something
about this girl."
And you know,
she's gone on to do great.
And so, you know,
we've had some great moments.
We've had some not
so great moments.
-Well, you've got you've had
a lot of moments.
I think it's hard to have all,
be one or the other.
I would imagine there's
a some sense of pride
when you see those people
having these careers.
I'm also wondering
what it's like you've produced
so much music
over the course of your career.
Do you still, does it
give you a reaction?
Does give you chills
or goose bumps
when you hear your music
out in the world?
-Yeah. Yeah, and it's very
interesting, Seth,
because our son, Eric,
who's now eight,
and I'm not making this up,
his favorite artist
is One Direction.
So he's playing these songs now
at eight.
And he's like, "Oh, Daddy
you know there's this artist
called One Direction.
What do you think about?
I'm like,
"Yeah, they're amazing."
So it's kind of gone
full circle, but I love it.
-Have you tried to jump in
and sort of explain
your history
with One Direction, are you...?
Because I would worry,
having kids myself,
that if I told them
I'm a part of something,
they would immediately not think
it was cool anymore.
-You are 100 percent right.
You've literally got to say
nothing.
-Yeah.
-"Daddy, knew them."
And that's about
as far as I've gone right now.
And as he gets a bit older
I'll tell him the story.
But it, it, it
it's yeah, I mean, you do.
I do get a personal buzz,
particularly with him,
when I hear him
playing a record.
And I think "Yeah, Daddy
that had the artist signed"
or made the record, whatever.
Yeah, it's cool.
-I very -- always fascinated
by early jobs in showbiz.
You're --
Is it true that your first job
was working on
the set of "The Shining"?
-Well, it was interesting
because when I was about 17,
I was a runner
on a. on a film set
and that is like
the the bottom job,
you know, when you're working on
a TV show, movie, etc., etc.
So I was a runner
and then I applied to be
a runner on "The Shining."
For some reason, don't ask me
why, Stanley Kubrick
would not hire runners.
I have no idea why.
I mean, it was like $20
a week or something,
so I got turned down.
And then it happened
that Stanley Kubrick
had bought my parents house,
and my dad bumped into him
a few months later and said,
Why didn't you give Simon
a job as a runner?
He went, "Oh, I didn't know it
was Simon."
So he did offer me the job back.
But by that point I had got a
job in the mailroom,
at EMI in music.
So I kind of went from
possibly being
in the film business into music.
So it was like a, like a
sliding doors moment, almost.
-So he actually did you
a great favor, it turns out.
-Huge favor, yeah, thanks.
-I mean, that, your broken back,
a lot's gone right for you.
-Silver lining.
-So you mentioned
your 8-year-old
and my last question
for you is,
have -- has he,
has your school,
have they ever reached out
and said,
"Simon,
we're doing a talent show.
-Yes.
-We would love to have you.
Has this moment happened?
-Just so happens
I'm normally out of the country.
[ Laughter ]
-You would, you would soften it
up for the eight year olds,
wouldn't you?
-I would.
But, Seth, imagine if he's
one of the people,
I've got to judge, I mean,
it would be horrendous.
I am really, really pushing him
to stay my side of the desk.
So he literally is
in training right now.
-Yeah.
And I think that's good.
And you're not that good a liar,
Simon.
So I think you should try to --
-Thank you.
-I think it's a good quality.
By the way, when people
aren't good liars.
It's nice to be able to know
how they're feeling.
Hey, thank you so much for
making the time for us tonight.
We really appreciate it.
-Seth it's been a real pleasure.
-Thanks for having me on.
-Simon Cowell, everybody.
"America's Got Talent Extreme"
airs Mondays at 8:00 on NBC.